check out this first story from the wall
street journal
barr tells prosecutors to consider
charging violent protesters with
sedition i love this
i actually looked up what sedition was
and there have been different sedition
acts
implemented in the u.s and i think the
the past several iterations have been
unconstitutionally repealed
to bring a sedition case prosecutors
would have to prove
there was a conspiracy to attack
government agents or officials that
posed an imminent
danger they say attorney general william
barr told the nation's federal
prosecutors to begin
aggressive to be aggressive when
charging
violent demonstrators with crimes
including potentially prosecuting them
for plotting to overthrow the u.s
government people familiar with the
conversation said
in a conference call with u.s attorneys
across the country last week
mr barr warned that sometimes violent
demonstrations across the u.s
could worsen as the november uh that
some sometimes
they could worsen as november
presidential election approaches he
encouraged the prosecutors to seek a
number of federal charges
including under a rarely used sedition
law
even when state charges could apply the
call underscores the priority mr barr
has given to prosecuting crimes
connected to violence during months of
protests against racial injustice
leading to major property damage as
president trump has made a broader
crackdown on the violence and property
destruction a key campaign issue
u.s attorneys have broad discretion in
what charges they bring
federal prosecutors have charged more
than 200 people with violent crimes
related to the protests most of whom
face counts of arson assaulting federal
officers
gun crimes fbi officials earlier this
year described the perpetrators as
largely opportunistic individuals
taking advantage of the protests in more
recent months police officials say they
are alarmed by the presence of armed
fringe groups from both sides
of the political spectrum mr barr has
blamed much of the violence on left its
extremists including antifa
a loose network of groups and people
that describe themselves as opposing
fascism
and which mr barr has described as a
movement advocating revolution
mr barr is not wrong they quite
literally carry signs that read
revolution nothing less
and what was that what did you say to me
what kind of revolution they want an
economic revolution is it an industrial
revolution
i mean uh i think they want a political
revolution
but they think is the key word there
they well in what context are they
saying revolution
there is no context the other is they're
marching around saying burn it down and
throwing bricks at cops
now there's context yeah they're
throwing bricks at cops and screaming
revolution
okay they're targeting maybe they want a
violent political revolution if that's
the case yeah then that's that's what we
got
you know what prevent you know what i
think man i don't think they actually
want anything
so one of one of the other stories we
were we were talking about is what's
going on with andy now
and uh there's a story written by
willamette
willamette yeah am willamette willamette
i've been pronouncing it wrong
apparently welcome to the new world
it weak and they highlight these two
antifa people who were like every day
they put on their protest outfits and
they go out together and
the you know the the boyfriend is the
drum on the on the front line playing
drums so he wears a bulletproof vest and
she's a medic so she puts on her medic
gear and i'm like
just play d and d like you know what i
mean like i'm going to be the medic
okay dungeon dragons right there you
know yeah
and then playing a game and then make a
video you know talking about your
beliefs and get
60 000 subscribers and change the world
that way
i don't know they're not even trying to
change the world i mean you got to get
your fantasy out
i agree you got a game or do something
to get your fantasy out but
they really want to change the world
otherwise they wouldn't be out there
i'll take some pool noodles
i will slide them over a mop and you can
whack each other all day and night with
it while screaming that you're you know
don't hit me i'm the medic i'm the medic
you're cheating you're cheating
you can still hit it you can still you
gotta go for the medic first actually
i guess okay so anyway we we can
definitely talk about that but i guess
the question is
sedition too far not far enough
doesn't go too far enough it doesn't go
too far too far enough
um okay so this means that they're
they're they're conspiring
and i think yesterday we talked about
that and i think that they are
conspiring
so the definition that i have first
edition is just
conduct or speech inciting people to
rebel against authority of state or a
monarch
and to me that's basically exactly what
they're doing like how else would you
describe marching in the street with
signs and throwing bricks literally
at cops and federal officers that is the
embodiment of the state right in front
of you
i mean they're straight up saying they
want to burn it all down you guys are in
reading about it a lot more than i am
i'm not getting
um an organized desire like command
to destroy the us government or at all
i'm just getting more of a violent anger
and lashing out maybe for regular people
but they're
it's being weaponized specifically by
extremists who want
to destroy like there's a group of far
left extremists
they're revolutionary communists they
want to overthrow everything
so they're going and finding anger from
people in the community
and then using that to to accomplish
their goals so
if regular people might just get charged
with some state level charge but then
you'll end up with
the actual organizers getting charged
with sedition maybe that makes sense
that might make a lot more sense i would
hate to see like frontline people that
don't realize
what they're involved in to get start
getting charged with sedition
yeah stupid people but that's that's
that's most of them i think i think this
is why they keep using the term
anarchists which you obviously
vehemently disagree with
oh yeah because they they just want to
destroy they don't actually have a
program that they're trying to put into
place because we talk about them like
wanting power and wanting communism but
i think
you're right i think they don't even
want that they just want to destroy
stuff
so well anyway look i looked up sedition
and the crazy
thing is so i i didn't know this there
were there were originally 17
amendments proposed articles proposed
for the first bill of rights
and then it got uh like that they like
they
they winded it down to condense it down
to two i'm sorry
two they connected down to two to uh 12
and then got rid of two the first two
and it's actually really funny but we've
actually had multiple instances of the
sedition act
so the first one president john adams
signed into law in 1798
it set out punishments of up to two
years of imprisonment for opposing or
resisting any law of the united states
or writing or publishing quote false
scandalous and malicious writing about
the president or the congress
yikes though not the office of the vice
president then occupied by adam's
political opponent thomas jefferson that
is like
that sounds like just hardcore
corruption
you know that sounds like definitely
heavy the president being like you can
make fun of the guy i don't like but
not me otherwise you go to jail yep so
check this out
this act of congress was allowed to
expire in 1801 after jefferson's
election to the presidency
jefferson pardoned those still serving
sentences and fines were repaid by the
government
this law was never repealed uh was never
appealed to the united states supreme
court
but opponents claimed it was
unconstitutional under the first
amendment
uh yeah it is and then we had another
one
in 1918. now and i guess this is because
of
world war one or whatever we had another
sedition act
dude i'm reading all this stuff this
country used to be way more
authoritarian
especially during world wars yeah or
wars in general
suspending what didn't like abraham
lincoln suspend habeas i believe he did
yeah
i've heard that he sure did and then and
then in world war ii
you had uh the office of censorship
which controlled the flow of information
into and out of the united states
yeah man the vietnam uh even the vietnam
conscription era was terrifying
terrifying i i used to live and be like
i hope i'm 27 before anything goes
quickly man i hope i'm 30 because it's
still the draft still exists
yeah it's just uh well now it's all
the they don't necessarily need need to
draft anybody but here's the craziest
thing so
i'm we're going to segue from bilbao and
this edition stuff into these these uh
antifa facing life in prison but i got
to highlight something
that i find uh really really interesting
so the
the the first uh in 1798 i got it
there it is in 1798 there were 17
articles approved by the house this is
for the bill of rights right
and then eventually we we ended up in uh
in september with 12.
the first two didn't make it the first
one had to do with like you can't change
the salaries of representatives or
something
whatever the first one was supposed to
set the amount of
representatives existed so the idea was
that
for every 30 000 people in the u.s you'd
get one representative
could you imagine how many how people in
the house you would have we'd have so
many we'd have like four what do we
measure like seven thousand or
if it was for every thirty thousand yeah
like it would be like ten thousand
dude but okay so this makes sense
because in order to represent
people you need a small group because
one person can't represent seventy
thousand people accurately i can't like
say i can't even represent you
accurately if i had to be like okay i'm
speaking for tim today
i could only do a little pretty good
accurate imagine doing
well so imagine 10 people that all had
different opinions or had somewhat
different opinions i
got and then now a thousand so i can see
why they want to limit it to 3
000 or whatever but then so what do we
have
000 30 000 do we have six thousand
representatives or is it a full so
flawed system
they didn't i don't think they predicted
how many people were gonna live in this
country and that was
that was it they're like yeah so they
said eventually it will be
no more than one for every fifty
thousand which would have brought us to
in 2010 6563 members of the house
you would need like a stadium for that
you need representatives for the
representatives
yeah yeah well almost you're getting
close so ineffective
yeah so ultimately this is still pending
before congress i guess
but the the the laws of for like the
sedition act of 1918 and whatever
it's uh oh here we go seditious
conspiracy so this is what i think
they're specifically
referring to if two or more persons in
any state or territory
or in any place subject to the
jurisdiction of the united states
conspire to overthrow put down
or to destroy by force the government of
the united states or to levy war against
them
or to oppose by force the authority
thereof or by force to
prevent hinder or delay the execution of
any law of the united states
or by force to seize take possess any
property
of the united states contrary to the
authority thereof they shall each be
fined
or imprisoned not more than 20 years or
both
oh and there it is for seditious
conspiracy charge to be affected
a crime need only be planned it need not
be actually attempted well
according to andre torres and jose jose
e velasquez
the accusation of seditious conspiracy
is of political nature
and was used almost exclusively against
puerto rican independ
independent disturs in the 12th and in
the 20th century not 12th 20th
however the act was also used in the
20th century against communists
wow the united freedom front neo-nazis
and terrorists
such as the provisional ira in
massachusetts and omar abdel rahman
well i think that actually makes sense i
mean when you look at antifa attacking
the federal courthouse in portland
they they were planning this they were
putting weapons there was like a
backpack found with with
commercial-grade fireworks explosives
bullets
and there was one magazines were found
with like red paint on them
so uh sounds like they were organized in
planning for a siege on a federal
building
and they were trying to break into it
dude that's it that's what this
law is for personalizing that so they
were trying to break in but can they
prove that people were planning to break
in
specifically they specifically went to
the federal building
to destroy the to harm and no there's
federal buildings that set it on fire
there's a video of them trying to cut
through the chains like welding tools to
like get
in the building the question i guess one
question is is it a political movement
this antifa thing or is it just like a
lash out against fascism
and and it's just fascism
corporate government collusion the
reason why i wanted to go through
these past edition laws is to make the
point we are so much more free today
than back then
it's like maybe that's maybe that's the
problem
we've actually become so free these
people are running around
unchecked unopposed and like we were
saying world war ii maybe those laws
actually helped us win the war
like it was crazy lockdown martial law
but we won the war and we'd have german
spies
sending information out of the country
as far as we know i mean that's a big
challenge in freedom versus security
authoritarianism can be efficient in the
short term
because it allows you to execute very
quick decisions and moves
but in the long term it completely
destabilizes a civilization because one
individual can't accurately plan a
long-term economy
and they can't uh they can't accommodate
everybody's desires so if we could turn
something on and then
automatically have sunset claws like
turn on some authoritarian move and then
have it disappear after two years
i'm i'm wary of any kind of emergency
powers you know you look at what's going
on in michigan governor whitmer
there's there's now 400 000 signatures
to strip the governor of michigan of of
her emerge of the existing
governorship's emergency powers because
how she's
how the governor today has abused them
they won't give it up
and the craziest thing is whitmer she's
she's the democrat in michigan who's you
know
locking everything down and she's nuts
she's basically telling
people she's straight up telling people
don't sign this
don't repeal my power do you think it
would be more effective to get her out
of office or to repeal the problem
of the office get the power out of there
so you don't like it's
executive action executive authority
makes you nervous
too much yeah too much we need it we
need a good amount this is not this is
too much
you you look at how she's abused people
and and uh
shut down like tiny barber shops run by
like little old men yeah dude
one person should not have that kind of
power when it comes to state law
and so anybody who tells me do like i
listen if i if i go to you and say we
got 400 000 people who say you have too
much power and they go
no and they're like i am the senate and
like
that and then fly at me with their saber
out yeah that person's got to go that's
a robin hood villain
that's that's the sheriff that's
literally palpatine yeah dude if if they
come in and say it's time for you for
you to give up your emergency powers
they should be like okay or at least
strip it for temporarily
no i mean look it's an emergency power
it's supposed to be temporary
we we are a country that requires the
consent of the governed for the
government to exist
there should never be a point where the
governor is like do not take my power
from me
right you defer to your populace yeah
400 000 people say
we've signed signatures for this my
response would be like can we do a
referendum
can we like put it on the ballot and
then have everyone go and they can say
yes or no and then
because emergency powers can work if you
need to move quickly
if you're like whoa we got a major
disaster i need to be able to move
faster
than a council can to protect the people
so barr do you like this emergency
this sedition concept man that's tough
um i feel like antifa if there was a
line
of like so first of all they're
criminals that's not even a question you
go out and you do these things you
organize the stuff
you're committing crimes some of them
some people may identify as antifa and
not be committing any crime no no i'm
specifically referring to them who
go out in portland and i would even go
as far to say if you are out there
and you watch someone throw an explosive
and you stay
you're helping them whoa dude that's
risky
wait wait so you mean if let me put this
away let's let's let's re
throwing an explosive is a very serious
crime i mean if i don't report a crime i
think that's
i didn't say i didn't see it to report
anything is it legal so if i see you if
i'm not walking my dog and i see you
throw a firebomb into someone's house
and i don't report that
is it is that illegal of me am i under i
don't i
i think there may be some jurisdictions
that i would have some but i think for
the most part no
you just run and what if i just stood
there and watched nothing exactly it's
not illegal to stay and watch
these people are linking arms and
they're standing
in front of everyone oh well that's
different but that's what they're all
doing
some people leave i'm not talking about
those people so if you if you're
if you're at one of these event and
you're holding a shield or you're
standing there
side by side and people are standing
next to you throwing things and you know
it
like ted wheeler was out there the mayor
of portland are throwing explosives
the way i describe it is this throwing
an explosive is a very very serious
crime
you could blow someone's hand off like
one cop that hit the leg and had to be
brought into the hospital for like an
emergency
you know medical treatment i don't know
exactly what happened with that but we
saw the photos of cops with like their
skin burned off from the explosions and
stuff like that
i'd argue throwing an explosive at
someone is probably worse
than robbing a bank robbing a bank is a
coercive demand
so i'll put it this way if one of these
antifa guys walks into a bank
imagine this way an antifa guy goes hey
everybody
we're all going to go inside this bank
and we're going to we're going to
protest the one percent and you said
okay you walked in and you're standing
next to him and then he raises a gun
and then he says give me all your money
now and you go this is great
and you're standing in front of him
while it's going down aren't you an
accomplice about it at that point yeah
but if i if it's on the street you're
across the street and you're throwing a
fire bomb and i'm 30 feet away from you
dressed like you cannot talk
i'm not necessarily part of that all
right let's try again let's say
this antifa guy says hey everybody we're
going to go to a bank and we're going to
protest the one percent by all wearing
the same masks
and then you say okay and you go in the
bank and and one guy with a mask raises
a gun and says
anybody move you're going to get busted
at that point you're helping them you're
conspiring
whether you meant to or not yeah so
there's there is a fine line between
how do we deal with those who have
chosen to stay and stand side by side
with those
who are laying siege to a federal
building to break in and cause damage
and those who thought they were going to
a peaceful protest and say i gotta get
out of here and sometimes you'll go
they'll be burning a building you don't
even know it a block away because you
don't see it
and then but that you're complicit
because you dressed like them
and you didn't run but i gotta i gotta
add i you'd think after 90 plus days
what what's what's the line
after 10 days of them laying siege to a
courthouse and you decide to go
i'll put it this way someone's robbing a
bank every friday and you're like i'm
gonna go next friday
and see what's going on if they're
sieging
federal property they're they should go
to jail they should be taken off
so all of these moms the mom block or
whatever where they're all linking arms
and
shielding antifa as they throw
explosives yeah man i think that crosses
the line now sedition
i don't know they're not organizing
they're just being dumb but are they
organizing
we don't know the wall of moms i mean
they coordinated their outfits yeah are
they on
telegram chat are they on facebook like
like encrypted chats where they're all
like getting funded and
there's no way no well there is i mean
i'm sure the government has ways of
tracking their communications to varying
degrees
but if they all show up wearing yellow
with mom written on their chests
someone told them what to do and they
did it right so
there's a line right that's what i'm
saying those people might get some kind
of charge
like when people start throwing
explosives and then a month later
you come down and shield them okay we
have to assume
we can we can we're not going to give
you the benefit of the doubt i'm going
to assume you must have known however
i don't think necessarily you can charge
them with a crime proving they they knew
but you don't give them the benefit of
the doubt so after the explosives are
thrown if they remain
than some you know light lower tier
charge the people who run
and say i don't have anything to do with
this thank you for leaving because these
people are disrupting this
please point out the extremists will
arrest them and then you can maintain
your peaceful protest
because once they started arresting
these people everything cleared up i
noticed that
everything cleared up and they did a
dance party and they got their peaceful
protest
and then all of a sudden it's gone dude
i wanted trump to send in the national
guard like
right away but could you imagine what
the states would have done it would have
been chaos i'm glad i mean i i
i'm naive but that's what i would have
done if i was the president i would have
said that to my advisors like let's send
them in and he probably did that
yeah and they were probably like the
mayor the governor
the eight the state ag they are going to
get everyone in opposition to you
you are going to have business owners
protesting you it would be it would be
total
total chaos and he said at the town hall
last night he mentioned the national
guard again they were like how would you
have
and he was like i want to set the
national guard but he was telling the
governors to call in the national guard
what he was saying was
i have the the availability just let me
know because then it would be up to them
yeah they didn't do it but trump shut it
down thanks for checking out this clip
from the tim cast irl podcast we do the
show live
monday through friday at 8pm so come
back to check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time